Imagine your brain is a computer, right?
And, uh, someone has secretly opened like 50 browser tabs in the background.
Oh, that sounds like a nightmare.
Right.
You can't even see them.
You aren't actively clicking on them, but you can hear this faint
endless hum of static just coming through the speakers.
And meanwhile, because they're all running simultaneously, your
battery is draining incredibly fast.
Yeah.
And you have no idea why you're so exhausted.
Exactly.
You are completely drained and you don't even fully know why.
So today we're doing a deep dive into the invisible, um, well, the
engine of fear that drives our most common anxieties and more importantly,
how you can systematically shut those background tabs down.
I love that analogy.
And we're pulling from a really fascinating source today for this.
It's an audio segment from a medical test prep guide called Pass Ready Prep.
Yeah.
Hosted by an instructor named Keek, right?
Right.
And it's originally designed to help medical professionals differentiate
between psychological conditions for their board exams.
But, you know, we're taking this out of the clinic and
straight into your everyday life.
For sure.
Because Keek uses this brilliant framing device that completely
changes how we understand anxiety.
Yeah.
The core concept here is treating the human emotion of
fear like a mechanical engine.
Biologically, I mean, that engine is essentially our amygdala, that
ancient threat detection center in the brain.
And what Keek points out is that three of the most high prevalence
anxiety disorders out there, they all share this exact
same underlying engine.
They run on the exact same fuel.
Yes.
But they look completely different on the outside based on how that
engine is running and where the mind decides to point the exhaust.
I just think that's such an empowering way to look at it.
When you treat anxiety as a mechanical engine, it stops being
this nebulous, overwhelming curse, you know?
Exactly.
You can start looking at the exhaust of that engine.
Like does it idle too high?
Does it backfire?
Yeah.
And recognizing those shapes of exhaust is really how you demystify
what is happening in the brain.
Right.
So if we start with the most diffuse form of fear, we're
basically looking at an engine that is just left idling too high all day long.
Yes, exactly.
This is generalized anxiety disorder or GED.
The diagnostic code for this one is F41.1.
And the defining keyword is right there in the name, right?
Generalized.
The engine of fear isn't pointing at a specific threat like, I
don't know, a bear in the woods or a tight deadline.
The worry spreads.
It really does.
CAKE specifically notes that it spreads across multiple everyday
domains like your work, your health, your family, your finances.
It's just this ambient dread.
But for it to actually be classified as GAD, CAKE stresses a
really strict timeline and has to run continuously for at least six
months, which made me wonder why six months?
I mean, why not just a really stressful month at work?
Well, because a stressful month at work is just a situational
reaction. The six month criterion is about proving that this is a
chronic mechanical issue in the brain software.
Ah, I see.
Yeah, by the time an engine has been running hot for half a
year, the brain has essentially built a new neuroplastic
pathway. It just assumes danger is always present.
So it's no longer a reaction to an event.
It's the new baseline.
Exactly. And that constant baseline takes a massive
physical toll on the body.
Yeah. Kuechly's restlessness, fatigue, trouble concentrating,
irritability, muscle tension and disturbed sleep, which honestly
brings us right back to that browser tabs analogy.
It really does. The battery drain is the fatigue.
Right. And the static is the trouble concentrating.
And the muscle tension happens because your body is
basically losing homeostasis.
Homeostasis, like the body's baseline.
Yeah. Homeostasis is your body's natural balance.
When that fear engine is constantly idling, your
sympathetic nervous system, the one responsible for fight or
flight is continually trickling adrenaline and
cortisol into your bloodstream.
Wow. So your body literally cannot power down.
It can't. So to fix this, Kuechly outlines a combination
approach for the first line treatment.
It's cognitive behavioral therapy paired with either
an SSRI or an SNRI.
Let's break those acronyms down for anyone who isn't a
pharmacologist.
An SSRI is a selective serotonin reuptake inhibitor, right?
Yeah.
And an SNRI targets norepinephrine as well.
Basically, serotonin is a mood stabilizing chemical in
the brain. So an SSRI acts like a dam, keeping
serotonin floating around in the brain's synapses a
little longer instead of being immediately absorbed
back up, which I guess helps quiet that background
static.
That's a great way to put it.
And that chemical stabilization is absolutely
crucial for the second part of the treatment, which
is cognitive behavioral therapy or CBT.
Because CBT is essentially software debugging, right?
Exactly. It teaches you to recognize irrational
thought patterns and systematically dismantle
them. But if your brain's alarm bells are ringing
at maximum volume, you can't focus on debugging
the software.
That makes total sense.
You can't fix the code if the computer's on
fire.
Right. So the SSRI lowers the volume of the
background hum just enough so the patient can
actually engage with the therapy.
They really work together.
Okay, that makes perfect sense.
Now, Kuech spends a lot of time warning medical
students about common misconceptions or what we
can call diagnostic illusions.
Yes, the traps.
The biggest illusion with GD is confusing it
with panic disorder, because on the surface, a
patient might just come in and say, I have
terrible anxiety.
Right. But the separator is the shape of the
exhaust. Like we said, GD is that persistent
spread out hum of worry.
Right. Whereas if GAD is the engine idling too
high, panic disorder is what happens when
someone suddenly slams their foot on the gas
pedal and just red lines the engine entirely.
Exactly. Which takes us right into our second
condition. With panic disorder and the code
for that is F-41.0, the defining feature isn't
hum at all. It is recurrent, unexpected panic
attacks.
And these are massive surges of intense fear
that peak within minutes.
Yeah, the biology of a panic attack is extreme.
It is a complete misfire of your survival
instincts.
Like your brain triggers a massive adrenaline
dump as if a tiger just walked into the room,
but you're just sitting on your couch watching
TV.
Right. Your heart races.
You might hyperventilate.
You might even feel chest pain.
But Keke points out a crucial diagnostic
criterion here.
Just experiencing these attacks isn't enough
to diagnose panic disorder.
Wait, I remember reading that and thinking if
you are having recurrent panic attacks, how is
that not panic disorder automatically?
Well, because the disorder isn't just the
spike itself.
To actually meet the criteria, the attacks must
be accompanied by at least one month of either
anticipating and worrying about the next
attack or fundamentally changing your
behavior to avoid having one.
Oh, wow. So it's the shadow that the spike
casts over the rest of your life.
Yeah, living in fear of the fear itself.
Like you stopped going to the grocery store
because you had an attack there once.
You're modifying your entire existence to
accommodate this misfiring engine.
Precisely. And this is where we run into a
major diagnostic illusion.
And honestly, perhaps one of the most
fascinating debates in how we treat anxiety.
Yeah, the medication debate.
Exactly.
Keek states explicitly that benzodiazepines,
which are fast acting sedatives, are a
highly tempting option for patients.
But they are absolutely not the first
line standard of care.
Right. The standard of care is, again,
SSRIs and CBT.
Right. But I have to play devil's
advocate here for a second, because if
I am a patient having a sudden
terrifying spike of panic, I
mean, a surge of intense fear that
peaks within minutes.
And benzos are known for working
incredibly fast to calm the nervous
system down.
Why are we told to be suspicious of
using them?
It's a fair question.
Right. If I'm terrified right now,
shouldn't the fast drug be the
answer?
It almost seems cruel to withhold that
immediate relief.
It is a perfectly logical assumption,
and that is exactly why it is such
a pervasive misconception.
It makes intuitive sense to want to
stop the pain immediately, but
it completely ignores the long term
mechanics of fear.
Oh, so.
Because treating panic disorder isn't
just about suppressing a symptom in
the moment, it is about fundamentally
rewiring how the brain interprets
physical sensations.
OK, but how does a fast acting
sedative prevent that rewiring?
Well, think about it.
If you take a fast acting sedative
every single time the engine
spikes, you never learn that the
spike itself isn't dangerous.
Oh, I see. Your brain thinks I
survived because I took the pill.
Exactly.
You never learn to tolerate the
physical sensations of your own
body.
And this is where a specific type of
CBT comes in, which is called
interoceptive exposure.
Interoceptive exposure.
So exposing yourself to your own
internal sensations.
Yes.
A therapist might literally have a
patient spin in an office chair to
induce dizziness or breathe
through a tiny straw to induce
shortness of breath or even run
in place to get their heart
racing.
Wait, really?
They make you do that on purpose.
Yes, you intentionally recreate
the physical symptoms of a panic
attack in a safe room.
Why?
To prove to the amygdala that a
racing heart is just a racing
heart, it is not a heart attack.
It is not lethal.
If you just numb the response
instantly with a fast acting
drug, you disrupt that crucial
learning process.
Oh, wow.
OK, so the quick fix is actually
a trap because it reinforces the
brain's false belief that the
panic attack was a lethal
threat, that it literally
required chemical intervention to
survive.
Exactly.
You have to actually ride out the
spike to prove to your brain
that the exhaust is just smoke.
You have to teach the engine
that it can redline and come
back down without exploding.
That is why the longer, harder
work of SSRIs and exposure
therapy is the actual cure.
That is incredibly eliminating.
All right, so we've discussed
the internal free floating fear
of GAD, right?
The engine idling too high.
Right.
And we've discussed the sudden
internal spikes of panic
disorder, the engine redlining.
Now, we follow Keek's logic to
what happens when you take that
fear engine and point the
headlights outward.
You point it directly at other
people.
Yes, this is social anxiety
disorder.
The diagnostic code is F40.10.
And with social anxiety
disorder, the distinguishing
feature is what Keek calls
the fear of scrutiny.
Yes, it is the profound fear
of being judged, embarrassed,
or negatively evaluated
in social or performance
situations.
Let's talk about why this
happens mechanically.
Because logically, being judged
by a stranger in a coffee shop
shouldn't feel like a life
or death scenario.
But for someone with this
disorder, it absolutely does.
It does.
And it really goes back
to evolutionary psychology.
For early humans,
being accepted by the tribe
was literally a matter
of survival.
Right.
If you were kicked out,
you were in trouble.
Exactly.
If you were judged, rejected,
and kicked out of the tribe,
you starved or got eaten
by predators.
So the brain's threat
detection center is hardwired
to view social rejection
as a physical threat.
That makes so much sense.
And in social anxiety disorder,
that specific alarm
is hypersensitized.
The fear of scrutiny
triggers the exact same
fight-or-flight response
as a physical attack.
The spotlight of scrutiny.
And just like the others,
the first line treatment cake
lists follows a really
familiar pattern.
It's CBT built heavily
on exposure, plus an SSRI or SNRI.
Right.
But cake brings up a golden rule
here for differentiating
social anxiety
from other conditions that look
very similar from the outside.
The rule is anchor on what
the person is actually afraid
of.
Yes, because you cannot just
observe a behavior.
You have to understand
the motivation behind it.
You have to know where
the engine is pointing.
Right.
And cake take brings up
agoraphobia
as the first major look-alike.
OK, let me try a scenario
to lock this in.
Imagine two people who both
decide to skip a really
crowded general admission
indoor concert.
They both stay home.
OK.
On the surface,
the behavior is totally
identical.
They're avoiding a crowd.
But if we anchor on what they
are actually afraid of,
the mechanisms completely
diverge.
Exactly.
The person with agoraphobia
skips the concert,
because they are terrified
that if something goes wrong
or if they have a panic attack,
the exits are blocked.
And they cannot escape
the mass of bodies.
They fear being trapped.
Right.
And the person with social
anxiety.
Well, the person with social
anxiety skips the concert
because they're absolutely
convinced that if they go,
everyone in the room
will be staring at them,
judging the way they're
standing, judging their outfit,
judging how awkward they look.
Yes.
They fear being watched
and found wanting.
The action is the same,
but the exhaust
from the fear engine
is completely different.
Escape versus scrutiny.
That perfectly illustrates
the concept.
If you only look
at the avoidance,
you end up treating
the wrong mechanism entirely.
Now, the second look-alike cake
mentions is avoidant
personality disorder.
Now, how does that differ?
Because someone
with an avoidant personality
clearly wants to avoid people,
which sounds exactly
like social anxiety.
They do overlap heavily
because both involve
a severe aversion
to social situations
due to feelings of inadequacy
or fear of rejection.
However, the separator here
is scope and timeline.
Scope and timeline, OK.
Yeah.
Cake notes that avoidant
personality disorder
is a pervasive, lifelong
personality pattern.
It is deeply ingrained
into how the person views
their core identity
across all aspects of life
constantly.
Like they believe they are
fundamentally defective.
Exactly.
Whereas social anxiety disorder,
while incredibly severe,
is a more focused situational
fear.
It triggers in specific contexts,
like public speaking or eating
in front of others.
So it's basically the difference
between a core personality
structure and a highly targeted
fear response.
It's like one is the entire
operating system of the computer
and the other is a really
aggressive computer virus that
only opens during
certain programs.
That is a brilliant way
to put it.
And you know, that synthesis
brings us to a really powerful
realization for you listening
right now.
We've gone through the timelines,
the specific therapies,
the biological misfires.
Yeah.
But if you look across all three
of these distinct disorders,
the background hum of GAD,
the sudden spikes of panic,
the spotlight of social anxiety,
the baseline first-line treatment
is remarkably,
almost surprisingly,
identical.
It really is.
Across the board,
the standard of care
fundamentally relies
on cognitive behavioral therapy
paired with an SSRI
to lower the baseline static.
And the CBT almost always
features a heavy dose
of exposure.
Which really begs the question,
why does this matter to you
if you aren't sitting down
to take a medical board exam
next week?
Why spend time understanding
the different shapes
of the sphere exhaust?
I think it's because recognizing
the shape of the anxiety
demystifies it.
Anxiety so often feels
like this overwhelming,
mysterious force
that just dictates a person's
life.
It feels like magic or a curse.
Right.
But when you break it down
into these mechanical parts,
it changes the entire paradigm.
It turns anxiety
into a specific targeted
mechanism.
And mechanisms can be
systematically dismantled.
Exactly.
When you can name the shape
of the fear,
you can apply the specific tool
designed to fix it.
If it is a persistent hum,
you know you need to address
the chronic idling
and reset homeostasis.
Right.
If it's a sudden spike,
you know you have to practice
interoceptive exposure
to write out the adrenaline.
And if it's the fear
of scrutiny,
you know you have to challenge
the evolutionary assumption
that judgment equals death.
It just takes away
the power of the unknown.
It is incredibly empowering,
even just as an observer
of human behavior,
to understand that the engine
of fear has predictable
patterns.
But you know, this also brings
us to something I've been
chewing on since I first
looked at Keek's notes.
There is a fascinating,
almost paradoxical
contradiction in how we
naturally respond to fear
versus how we actually
heal from it.
Oh, yes.
I know exactly what you mean.
If you look purely
at the treatment protocols,
especially for panic disorder
and social anxiety,
Keek notes that a key symptom
is changing your behavior
to avoid the trigger.
Right.
Avoidance is literally
a diagnostic criteria.
But then the treatment
relies entirely on exposure.
Exactly.
The symptom is avoidance.
The cure is exposure.
If the ultimate fix
for the engine of fear
across all these conditions
is to actively face it,
to intentionally recreate
the panic attack,
or to intentionally walk
into the crowded room,
what does that tell us
about the fundamental nature
of fear itself?
It suggests something profound
about the human condition.
It suggests that fear actually
runs on the very avoidance
we use to try and protect
ourselves from it.
Wow.
So every time we step away,
we are feeding it.
Precisely.
Every time we choose
the quick fix sedative,
or skip the concert,
or avoid the difficult
conversation,
we think we are putting
the fire out.
Because we feel
that immediate relief.
Right.
But mechanically, we are pouring
fuel directly into the fear
engine.
We are confirming to the brain's
threat detection center
that the situation was indeed
life threatening,
and that running away was
the only reason we survived.
So we are basically
cementing the neuroplastic
pathway of fear.
We feed the engine
by running away.
Which means the only way
to starve the engine
is to stand still,
to let the exhaust wash
over you until your amygdala
finally realizes it's just
smoke.
Yes.
It completely flips
our survival instincts
upside down.
You have to move toward
the thing your brain is
screaming at you to run from.
It is the ultimate paradox
of anxiety.
Healing requires you
to tolerate the discomfort
you have spent your whole
life trying to escape.
And that is a really powerful
realization to walk away
with today.
Thank you so much for joining us
on this deep dive.
We hope this look
at the engine of fear
gives you a new lens to view
not just clinical diagnoses,
but the everyday anxieties
we all navigate.
Absolutely.
The next time you feel
the engine revving,
don't run from the exhaust.
Keep questioning,
keep exploring,
and remember to look closely
at the shape of the things
that scare you.
We'll catch you next time.